hello hi there my name is Nicole Nicole
I had a question for Frank Dillane he's
one of my favorites what it was the
hardest thing that you've ever had to do
so far and he's in this series well it
depends on on the scene I suppose like I
solder all this technical technicalities
of the blood is quite horrible to be
honest and hard I suppose in one way and
God I don't know it's actually a good
question I'm not sure what the hardest
scene was watching you eat when we're at
lunchtime and he's covered in blood he's
literally his arms are just out we have
to like hand feed him because he can't
everything's stuck together and he just
sits there like a baby bird well
physically don't break my seemed on the
very first episode with the theme of you
in the hospital yeah I think that was
that was if I found that oh yeah that
was that was a good scene it was a good
scene by was it was you know the one
where he's in the bed and yeah when he's
having a nightmare and he wakes up and
yeah ain't now on and he and you going
crazy in your head not knowing whether
things are real or not yeah with the way
he's seen is real Wow cool thank you for
your question
yeah yeah yeah thank you what is your
name
hi my name is Humana
we know her by the way well now that the
characters are developing where do you
see your characters actually going or
what do you want them to do more of just
go down the line well I guess one thing
is that we're all divided now so in the
second half of this season we really
start to see each character on their own
individually with an individual focus
which leaves them so much more room for
alliances and you know I guess breaking
apart more but we just get to see them
individually that's really exciting
I think the Travis Travis is obsessed
with family and it's like it doesn't
matter these an apocalypse or
civilization is fallen or where their
son's going crazy or medicines like
living with strand you know it's like
he's not flirting with dreams oh she's
not maybe not I think I think Travis is
gonna be really want to pull his family
together and then and and and build a
family again I think that's the most
important thing for Travis that's what I
want to see anyway I think Madison I
want to see her really start to adapt
and accept things and really adapt and
maybe I'd like to explore some of her
past yes
oh well I just have this theory and I
don't know if it's true and I don't know
if it'll ever have but I just feel like
she's I feel like she's the connective
tissue to the other show in some way I
just feel like one day that's gonna be a
phone call like yo Rick it's your cousin
Madison Grimes you know you know that
new sound you're looking you know like I
just feel like that is that the way I
sound no it's the back of the future
joke but I feel like or like maybe she's
Andrea's third sister's like I feel like
there's some connection with her because
she's a little southern there's
something about I don't know if that's
ever gonna happen
robber cursors stop Chris all right
Queen Jers own danger no where would you
where would you like to see strand go I
think about one stranded to see where he
has some more compassion and
how he can his journey as I think I
don't know being able to decimate a
human being with his words but how he
can really lift up humanity even more so
I like to see that and then I like from
the find a weapon at some point in a
costume and thriller maybe do thriller
maybe do thriller
well you have to do thriller oh yeah I
mean it's required you have to do
thriller you have the zombies you have
to do thriller and put it in the next
season maybe for next next year's
comic-con that would be if we just move
these tables back and you just did like
the seven done oh my god it's on the
same that would start working on that
now please I'm begging you what is your
name and what is your question my name
is Rebecca and I was wondering if the
political earned occurrence were all
part of the idea from the beginning or
did they just kind of happen as the
storyline progressed starting from the
comic or the shows the shows
yes week um it it was it was not planned
we weren't trying to pull Emma sighs but
I do think I mean one of the great
things about the genre is that it does
tap into whatever fears whatever phobias
whatever's going on in the world I think
you can you know inject that into the
dead and then you get to kill them you
know so I think that's probably to me so
sort of primal that's why people respond
to the genre so much and love to off
some bees so but no I wasn't it's it's
it just sort of happened yeah it's not
something that's ever really overtly
present for us on either show but you
can't really help but you know address
some of that stuff in the story you know
subject matter that we're dealing with
all right
what is your name and what is your
question hi my name is Liliana my
question is I you guys deal with
personal journeys of each of your
characters and they're often very flawed
but they are changing and evolving so I
wanted to know how are the characters
influencing you and your evolution oh
good let's start with Lorenzo on that
one I think that's a good places yeah
yeah it's great great are you saying me
as a person like in real life
or yeah I think she's yeah yeah how was
my character changing me um I think he's
helping me realize you know what I'm
gonna bring this up it's really opened
my eye to what's going on with bullying
in the world and and I've met a lot of
people that have told me what my
character has been going through has
really brought an awareness of bullying
so and and I met a mom that her son or
daughter passed away because she was
bullied and all that stuff so I I would
say that's really Chris has taught me to
really look at someone and not think
about myself but to think about what's
going on in their life and how can I
help them you said you're talking about
bullying I think a couple people thought
you said bowling bit of an ass Oh
bowling like I was like well we thought
was he doing a bit and then you're like
and then a mother can't even like who
has ever bowling bowling has never
killed anyone every guy said bowling
like yeah we thought I'm so sorry
great I just gave like my political
candidate speechless now I'm a freaking
bone where I'm like Chris is here now
he's lost it oh bullied bullying yeah
you know what's amazing about is that
you were so earnest and so I don't think
anyone to go what's your problem but I'm
leaving I'm leaving now bullying yes
that is a much better message than
bowling it's gonna make some like comic
books I do like Lorenzo James Henry
stands up for bowlers everywhere my dad
was a professional bowler I was very
unborn I was I was gonna we were gonna
have a lot to talk but I was also
bullied so there you go I get both I'm
both worse let's what about Alicia what
about for you is what have you learned
from your character oh well not such a
deep note but you know practically I
have actually learned how to
use a switchblade yeah which is pretty
good I am I got I got to use a butterfly
knife I'm in episode 4 I think of this
of this season and I've had it in with
me kind of since and so slowly over the
the months we've been working the stunt
guys have taught me a couple of tricks
so now I'm actually not so bad I mean
maybe a few of you would disagree
because I know I dropped it many times
in front of everyone but yeah yeah
that's kind of what I've learned learned
a lot about badminton camping again so
on a serious note I think I've seen
Ophelia progress from such a weak meat
character and I love seeing strong women
and so I just yeah go girls girl power
so I just really want to have her new
nickname season three Robert Kirkman
Dave Erickson
be something along the lines of hammer
face or public face or hatchet face and
I just want her toe in people's faces
with said objects I mean never behave if
you were on talking dead I could never
seriously say so what's the emotional
journey for hammer face Ben well in
season three mr. Hardwick all right what
is your name and what is your question
hi my name is Anna and my question is
what was your perception of Mexico
before going there and if you're
planning maybe to shoot season 3 there
also yeah well it was it was a couple of
things that were intriguing I mean one
was shot in Los Angeles in season one
and we really wanted to hold on to an
urban backdrop as we move forward and
what we will see more of this season in
addition is sort of a rural backdrop
we'll also get into shooting Tijuana and
the neighborhood surrounding so that's I
mean and that's something we'll be
looking forward to in season 3 as well
hopefully but it was it's it's just such
a really rich textured layered place and
it's beautiful the shoots and the crew
has been offense
I mean it's been it we just always felt
like it was the right place for the
story when we made that move so you know
hopefully that will continue and the
food is fantastic thank God for the oil
and what I hate there I think we've all
gained some weight there in fact I think
the best restaurant in the world is in
Tijuana which I never could have
predicted which is called misión DAC
Nueve and if you guys have a little
extra time you should check it out all
right um it's definitely worth the drive
I think we have time for a few more
questions what is your name sir bill hey
Bill what's your question questions for
Gale Anne Hurd could we see Burt Gummer
from tremors in The Walking Dead
universe I think he would have survived
fair question
fair question yeah absolutely you know
it's funny is that the TV series tremors
shot in the exact same studios where
we're world filming so there might even
be some props left over I think we left
I think we left a graboid down there I
just don't just pick it up one day
absolutely
yeah I think I think the cast could
learn a few things I think a few things
from him I mean he is a survivor what is
your question hi my name is Maya and my
question is from looking at the promo
poster on a scale from one to ten how
much dear that'll swear those imagery
are we gonna get seven seven seven and a
half maybe eight seven and
three-quarters I don't know how to say
three-quarters what is your name sir
what is your question hi my name is
Alejandra from Mexico and I'm wondering
who do you think
negan killed in the walking dead for the
purpose of the story
who would you like to do that [ __ ] kale
oh yeah Chris Hardwick what do you think
it's just that I like other people more
than you it doesn't appreciate it you
know I made your show pop I was speaking
in Spanish I don't know what I was
saying
I'm sorry none of us have an answer for
you none of us have an answer for you
I'm so sorry you came all this way so
the future the Walking Dead panel but
you come back you should come back in
like 30 minutes and go my question is is
Madison and strand gonna hook up or just
like something what is your name what is
your question
hello my name is Blas I am from Tijuana
yeah I have a question guys but policia
raises pindalest have to be part in this
particular phenomenon can we can see she
and another episode and how did you be -
how do you feel to be part about and in
this particular project
I mean Patricia is amazing we may see
her again
I mean she's one of those it's one of
those actors where I'd love to bring her
back the subsequent season is completely
different character you know but it's
she I mean she gave us so much in season
1 and I just I feel like you know there
may there may be a window where we get a
chance to see her again this season
possibly and maybe beyond but I would
you know I'd love to be able to do that
just I love her so much
what was the second part of the question
I think it was what was your what's your
favorite part of the what's your
favorite part of the project shooting a
mix up an old man hi what's your name hi
I'm hi sky what's your question
my question is if you guys were going to
die a horrible death Oh sky getting real
on the show okay good good important
distinction what would you like it to be
out of the melody waves you're in sky
sky it's a - but you're earning my
favorite part of comic-con that was
amazing
yeah let's go down the line Coleman yes
the end I'm gonna take notes what a
horrible way would you like to die on
this for some reason I think this strand
would die in the most ridiculous fashion
like being stung by a bee it's swelling
up and you know there's no medication
and then he just you know expires I'd
probably drive that little uh what was
that called that little speedboat I was
always driving
so do I bleed rive the zodiac right into
the Abigail what nice Travis old age I
should fully swallow hand-grenade and
just ruin everyone's clothes with other
brain matter no wait you don't die
that's how you become hammer face
Jackson Utley shoots herself come hammer
face Alicia I went like a West Side
Story duel with Madison and Alicia just
like knife off all that or a piano
falling on my head I mean it's final
well that would have to be a musical
knife off then you guys would have to be
I'm always that would be but who would
win now who would win yeah I would yeah
because Madison would never be able to
stab her own donor and then she'd get in
there and that's how she would that's
how she'd get her uh Lorenzo I think
Chris gonna be riding like a horse like
just in Tijuana somewhere and then he's
fighting and then he just gets killed on
the
oh you could have said bowling they
would have been a great call back this
is why you're the comedian and I read
lines okay
all right a lot of the internet would
disagree with me since you're new to
this season like what have you have you
dreamt about how you would want Luciana
I think I would like to die Dancing
thriller nice everybody's after well I
sky you're awesome and I hope you have a
wonderful comic-con and that was a great
question we have time for one more
question are you funny just to see sky
around comic-con walking with random
people how would you want to die what is
your name my name is Lila hi Kris hi
Lila what's your question um my question
is for Robert Kirkman and Greg Nicotero
um first of all thank you for everything
you do your shows are amazing um how
much more do you enjoy working on fear
than the Walking Dead and what's Lots
but I'll have a different answer on the
next panel so how's this one different
for you breathe well I mean being able
to go back and do things that we missed
I mean a lot of people I guess you know
we talked about how people were
frustrated by it but the idea of not
knowing what a zombie is when you were
being attacked by it I think it's very
you know the audience that's very
familiar with the Walking Dead is like
yeah why are they trying to talk with
this thing why are they trying to reason
with it but that to me is what's so
great about this show is dialing things
back and seeing how it is humanity
really works and if any of us were
actually confronted with a zombie in
real life we would kill it then we would
find out it was actually a human being
and we would all go to jail
you know and so and the walking dead
would have done us a terrible disservice
and I would apologize to all of you but
not really care at the end of the day
unless I knew the person but anyway so I
think being able to explore those things
is is really a lot of fun and is an
opportunity that we didn't really get to
have with the other show because Rick
Grimes was just out of his coma and yeah
we picked it up and wrapped it up
several weeks in I think on on The
Walking Dead
because we've been around for a long
time we're a couple years in we play up
the decomposition and that gives us a
very different palette than we have on
fear and I think as the series
progresses and we get into the season 3
I think we're gonna start expanding that
expanding that palette as well
so excellent they're both great they're
both the Blasted
you